Voiceover:Vectors A and B are drawn
in the interactive graph below.
Click to graph the terminal point of the
vector obtained by adding A and B,
who's initial point is the origin.
So we want to add A and B.
So let's see.
So vector A, we're going to
start at the tail of vector A.
And so vector A takes us right over here.
And then if we were to put
vector B, if we put it's tail
at the head of vector A,
and so essentially shift
vector B over like this,
we see that vector B,
we're going to go in the X
direction negative three,
and in the Y direction positive three.
So over here you would
go in the X direction
negative three, and in the Y direction you
would go positive three, just like that.
So this right over here would
be the head of A plus B,
Notice vector A and then if we
were to shift vector B over,
right over here, vector B
would be right over here,
and so A plus B would start
at the tail of vector A
and go to the head of
our shifted vector B.
You could have done it
the other way around.
You could have said, "Oh, B plus A.
"Let me just take this vector
and shift it over here,
"so this vector goes
four in the positive X.
"direction and one in the positive Y."
Four in the positive
X, one in the positive
Y would have gotten you to the same point.
It doesn't matter whether you're
adding A plus B or B plus A.